i have no apologies chair right
um are we corrupt
yes we are chair would you like uh
sandra to read a role call
yes please thank you sir
councillor brenton president
councillor bright president
councillor bushby president councillor
christie
yeah councillor dart
not present councillor hicks
present councillor hutchins but i think
he's going to be a few minutes late
councillor james president
thank you
right the first item on the agenda are
the minutes of the meeting held on the
25th of january
that was the budget special and the
meeting of the 1st of february
pages 4 to 16. i will read the pages
from the bottom of the sheet
we're looking for inaccuracies first of
all
page four five
six seven
eight counselor locks raise their hand
yeah i just like to say on page seven of
the minutes it clearly sets out that um
cnr did understand what we were doing
and we resolved that
a to d would be um resolved by the c
r and it was only the recommendations
e to h that was sent to full council so
i think that's quite clear in the
minutes
thank you thank you
eight
nine
10 11
[Music]
4 12
13.
14 15
16. so you're happy with the accuracy
so they shall be dealt with assigned
now we move on to item three the
action list you have to listen
here
our second the first and propose a
second thanks to james
so do we have a second up for the second
lot
i was second both lots of minutes
they're proposed and seconded my
apologies we have to formally
accept them so sandra
thank you chair councillor brenton
uh support the first uh set abstain from
the second
councilor bright against for the first
and that's staying for the second
yeah why not okay thank you councillor
christie
yeah for and for both thank you
councillor dart
sandra yes um paul thank you
councillor hicks four for both
councillor chins i don't think he's
arrived yet has he
councillor james or for both
chancellor laws four for both
chancellor locke all the boats and
slimmer golf
or for both and councillor wiseman
all for both of them thank you
the first minute
did you want the vote or no
uh you better record it yes ten
for the first set of minutes there's ten
four and
one against
and the second set there's nine four and
two abstentions
okay thank you we now move on to the
action list you have it in front of you
anyone any comments or amendments to
make
okay it's actually nothing on the action
list it's been all completed
[Music]
proper job all completed haven't they
been busy bunnies
right next item number four
public contributions
i've had no notification of anyone
wishing to speak
uh but there are statements which have
been received
steve i am to you
okay there's no statements received
either so we've got no public
contributions at all
well proper job item
five the forward plan
you've seen it on page 17.
anything to be said on that one any
comments to make
councillor haines
yep thank you chad um i think you've got
affordable housing under my name
coming up in um april
um presumably that will be a re i mean
where are we with that because my motion
was about a year ago i think
so what will
what form will that take uh on at the
april meeting
will it be a report about options to do
with affordable housing or what
please okay shall i come back please
steve
um yeah that's it's all on there because
i know this emotion that hasn't gone
through
the the committee process yet and
members
will be aware that john walter reported
back to
leadership at the last meeting progress
of that piece of work um with the intent
of holding a workshop for
members shortly and it'll be from that
workshop
that the exact amount of work uh that's
required
for that uh notice a motion will be
developed chair
so there won't be a report in april it's
cut it's held on there
as a record of a notice of motion that
hasn't gone
fully through the process yet thank you
right thank you
anything further no
right we move on item six declarations
of interest you've all been on the
council long enough to know the rules
now
but for benefit of members of the public
this refers to the fact that if members
have
a pecuniary or a family or any interest
in any item they have to declare it
and keep clear of the meeting and the
vote
in other words they will not influence
the situation
and they all know their responsibility
to do so
item seven is agreement of the agenda
between parts one and two for members of
the public what this means is that if
there are
matters where finance of individuals or
local companies or
that sort of thing are to be discussed
then they are not to be discussed in the
public domain
so that we ask the public to leave the
meeting when we move into part
two there are a couple of items at the
agenda of the item for part
two most of it will be held in part one
where your presence will be welcomed
item eight urgent matters of information
to be brought forward by myself
i have nothing have you got anything
steve um
no sorry chair but with the item seven
because there are part two
items you need the the agenda to be
agreed
so you need a proposal that you have
part two items
from the council of laws is seconding
can we put the formal vote that we will
have the agreement of the agenda
with items 16 and 17 as part two
thank you chair councillor brenton or
councillor bright or princely bushby
[Music]
i don't think he's alright councillor
james or
penciller laws or penciller lock
or pencil mcgoff or
councillor wiseman or that's unanimous
chair
thank you my apologies trying to move on
with this agenda item nine
smart biosphere funding requests this is
a report from um sean is it
thank you chair um the economic
development officer will present this
one for us
this afternoon
thank you chair
uh not sure if anyone can hear me all
right but i'm sure you'll be delighted
that i'm not going to be going through
the report
so there's a lot of necessary detail
within it um
needless to say the smart biosphere is
an important project both for creating
economic change
and for environmental considerations and
hence why it was unanimously supported
by the member climate emergency working
group now
in the week after consulting giants
accenture
reported that demand for ai cloud and
robotic skills
is soaring but skill levels are not
keeping up
i would move that members approved to
provide eighteen thousand pounds worth
of match funding
uh to the smart biosphere business case
development as per the report
thank you chair
where is this to be funded from chris
uh i believe it's from uh in fact i'm
gonna
see the ground to sean there because i
think he's uh
sorry the head of communities in place
on that one
thank you chair so so as in the
recommendation in the reports
it's to be funded from the habitat
regulations assessment
pyt fund which is a an an historic fund
that we had it's torridge money it's not
ring fenced in any way
and you are able to use it for this
purpose if you so much
move a recommendation chair
is there a second uh
chair cancer james well councillor james
ii did
council of laws you wish to speak uh yes
just very briefly because this report
at first sight is pretty heavy going
but when you get into the nitty-gritty
of it as the committee did
it's absolutely vital we've got to haul
ourselves up this list we've got to get
new money into this area
and and and this is going to give lots
of opportunities
and yeah i just totally support it
counselor dart
thank you chair um i'm just a little bit
tentative over this because
well yes it is relatively heavy going i
suppose but actually
what it contains could be phenomenal
however it's almost quite frightening
with it
because it sort of gives the impression
of a bit of an eye in the sky
um you know bringing forth
um this artificial intelligence that
will be watching over us and monitoring
um various aspects of soil river
at the moment it's fairly as i could
interpret it
appears fairly um basic technology
but it's giving the go-ahead for more
and more and more intrusion
into privacy and that actually is a bit
worrying i think you know we get all
excited about jobs and economy and it's
absolutely paramount and i'm really
excited because it could well
you know benefit my children's future in
fact perhaps i want to declare an
interest but ultimately
it will benefit all of us but it will
massively change
everything if it comes to fruition in
the way that is stated in this report
and um from that point of view i'm just
slightly wary but i suppose that's
that's
modern life going forward and i suppose
we've all got to accept it but
um yeah it seems a lack of privacy is a
an ever-growing issue um the other thing
i did note in the report
and maybe it's the way i read it was
under um
on page 22
in the table under education
it says create smart tech education and
research opportunities
to ensure northern devon is left
behind i'm assuming that's a typo
and they're not deliberately ensuring
that northern devon
is left behind or have i read that
incorrectly
right uh chris fuller firstly
thank you uh chair and thank you
councillors arts um
councillor i think that your concerns
are the exact
reason why the concept of smart cities
have failed before um
if there's a sense of intrusion and a
creeping
negative presence this isn't going to
work
so this is very much about how we kind
of move it forward with community
support building that from schools
um upwards to create positive change
rather than any way suddenly launching
into kind of
as you say a big brother states that's
not what for me
the communities of northern devon are
about or should ever be about
i know that's shared by the um smart
biosphere
group and yes in terms of a typo you're
absolutely right
it's the absolute opposite of that it's
a determination to make sure that
northern devon is not left behind but
that also kind of
new opportunities are created through it
uh councillor locke next member of the
committee
yeah i was going to raise the same point
as anna i read the same so i'm glad that
you cleared that up um i was going to
ask on page 27
how much is actually held in our habitat
regulations assessment fund
first point and on page 19 in the last
paragraph it talks about
where the um we're not in an enterprise
zone
um we're the only area south of stoke on
trent so where is
our nearest enterprise so if someone
could tell me how much we've got in the
fund
and what is our nearest enterprise
certain please
in terms of the enterprise zones and
there are some bringing the
exeter and plymouth uh university areas
and then sort of going up uh the m5
corridor as well
in terms of the fund again i'll have to
see the ground on that one to
uh the head of communities in place
chair i'm hoping that uh that david
hayes will be able to help me with that
one because i don't have the balance of
the front in front of me
i'm just trying to find the email where
i've
sort of run sean sean david hayes is
opening a spreadsheet as we speak i'll
come back to the committee
right we'll move on to councillor
leather a moment
thank you chair well like anna
a word of caution anything with the word
smart in front of it be very wary
smart motorways think about those smart
meters think about those
so um whilst we all want to increase
uh the the wealth in the area
the opportunities in the area if you
look at the map that was shown in here i
don't think we're going to get a great
deal in north devon
from this at the end of the day but you
know it's
18 000 pounds worth trying it for that
but beware of things that's
of smart in front smart bios fits
ridiculous
thank you chair okay david hayes
there's 39 000 pounds in that reserve at
the moment sure
okay
okay i've got no one else wishing to
speak
i believe i had it proposed and seconded
you did i'm gonna put it to the vote
thank you chair councillor brenton four
pencil bright oh cancer bushby
abstain councillor christie
oh cancel a dart
or councillor hicks
against councillor hutchins
um as i joined late i will abstain from
that decision thank you
okay thank you councillor james four
councillor laws or
councillor locke or councillor mcgoff
abstain counselor wiseman
or that's eight
four chair one again and three
abstentions
thank you right we move on to item
10 kenworth tree planting
that's me chair thank you very much good
afternoon everybody
and back to the north and biosphere
again
this time in relation to tree planting
the biosphere secured approximately 60
000 pounds worth of uh
funding and are seeking to carry out a
tree planting scheme in
kenwood valley um it's on land
and that's owned by uh areas of land on
by ourselves
and the the bridge trust and also
kingsley school
and so would be seeking permission for
the the tree planting to be carried out
on
our portion of the land as well as
licence to
put in fencing works um around the area
as well
and the cost of the or the the funding
also includes
maintenance costs for up to um five
years
um and in the report i've provided a
plan
of the area that the tree planting
relates to um
that's pretty much it chair i'm happy to
take any questions
okay councillor christie
yes i was just going to declare an
interest actually you would have heard
the words british trust there and
obviously
you know just being chairman of the
british trust um
it's not it's a non-financial interest
but this is a really good scheme
actually
and uh you'll see that all three ward
members have supported it
so i propose it but we go ahead with
this
is there a second uh oh second nature
casey bushby
thank you uh
councillor leather wishing to speak yeah
just briefly chair
does that sixty thousand pounds grant
include any section
section one or six money because
the baker's site in wooder road at apple
there's offsetting uh some of the
some of the contributions from there i
was led to believe are going
in towards this scheme is that correct i
believe that's correct councilor leather
it's not all through grant funding but i
think the ground funding prompted
um the the the start of this scheme
and then they got the 106 funding as you
described
thank you
anyone else wishing to speak
right we'll move to the vote it's
proposed and seconded
thank you chair councillor brenton or
anthony bright or cancer bushby
or pencil christie oh
penciller dart
ball penciller hicks or
that's the hutchins or penciller james
or pencil and laws
counselor lock or pencil mcgoff
or councillor wiseman or
don't that's unanimous chair thank you
item 11 the borough
center changing places facility
i don't know who's going to take this
one
here
thank you chair um this is just an
update for members
on on progress and in particular the
funding for the changing places facility
members will be aware that
the meeting in september last year
members approved the visitor center with
a series of recommendations and one of
those recommendations was to come back
to you
for funding for the changing places
facility
and the reason for that originally was
that when the government announced that
there would be
requirements for changing places
facilities
there were going to be grants made
available at the time of
drafting this report those grants have
not not been available
specifically for us to progress in time
to continue with the build so
what we're doing here is is basically
seeking approval to spend the money that
we have within the project
and within the contingency fund to fit
out
the changing places uh toilet facility
so um basically uh the detail is in the
report
um but uh in essence
we we are we are on we're on track uh
pretty much with the overall
program and um project uh
generally including remaining within the
original funding parameters and grant
funds for the project
but because we needed to obtain this uh
approval from you we've set out
the the actual cost of the changing
places facility on page two of the
report which you'll see there is about
twenty seven thousand pounds
um that sum is actually included within
our contract some with the contractor
because we wanted to get that
competitively priced at tender stage
so that that is the element that is
included there
and we're seeking your approval to
basically commit to that expenditure and
finish that
facility um in parallel with that we
have actually uh
the economic development team have tried
to see whether the
grants are available that have recently
come on
stream in the last week or so
for changing places facilities
unfortunately we're not going to be able
to get through the
application process to get the funding
in time to deliver it
for this project although i know chris
has already asked the question whether
we could have some
funding for this doesn't look like
that's likely
in this instance and it also doesn't
look like um actually the site would
be valid anyway from a location point of
view so
hence um we moved to the recommendation
at the bottom of page two
which is um that you uh approve the
inclusion of the changing places
facility within the costs that are
already in the contract some
and uh the remaining contingency sum
that we have
um to enable that element of the project
to be completed as part of the overall
build
thank you thank you we're between a rock
and a hard place
councillor locke yeah i mean i'm all for
getting this facility finished um
asap and up to all standards my only
query is
and it came across in one of my parishes
last week
if you complete a project using your own
funds
and then you apply for grant funding
are you discounting yourself and i was
told
if a parish of mine completed a
playground project didn't wait for the
section 106 monies that were allocated
and they complete using their own funds
and then when the section 106 money is
available the developer might turn
around so
you don't need it because you completed
the project so this wouldn't apply
whatever grant funding
well actually quite uh quite correct
counselor that's that's really why
i'm asking for this to be included
within the project funds because once
we've completed the work
we won't be able to apply for grant
funding retrospectively
but equally if we delayed the project to
secure funding one we've got the risk
that we might not be successful and also
the costs involved in delaying that
element with of the works would mean
that it would actually cost us far more
if we came back and tried to fit it out
later on
thank you in that case i will propose
that the funding is made available
pencil laws uh yes
um interesting to hear that there's a
funding stream
now uh online for changing places
facilities um am i to presume
as a matter of course that we will
pursue that
i mean our major towns
could really benefit tremendously by
having
one facility in each town i know they're
expensive
but we have not only a big visitor base
we have a lot of shall i say more mature
residents
who could benefit from this thank you
chair
right i'm looking for a secondary still
our second council
no one else wishing to speak
i'll put it to the vote
thank you chair councillor brenton
counselor brenton
sandri looks like he's away from his pc
so you might want to come back to him
okay thanks tom councillor bright
four councillor bushby
against
hutchins or councillor james
or penciller laws
counselor lock councillor mcgoff
poor councillor wiseman
or councillor brenton
no he's still not back sandra
okay
okay um
that's ten four and one against chair
and obviously no vote from cancer
brenton
okay thank you we now move on to item
11.
no item 12 submission of planning
applications pages 32-34
thank you chair um this report is purely
to seek approval to
submit some planning applications for
works on council owned land
and in the in the report there are um
a series of sites there where we need to
apply for
planning permission and obviously seek
member approval to do that the first one
um on page one there um item one is the
work that
has been completed at westwood ho um the
coastal engineer has obviously completed
those works
uh for the interim defense part of which
obviously was progressed without
the applica planet formal planning
application because the
final detail could not be known
at the outset um that is now completed
and so we need to
submit a retrospective planning
application to regularize those matters
um uh the the actual application has
already been prepared by
the team working with the environment
agency consultancy
team and uh with your approval we'd like
to submit that one please
um the second one is that um
we are uh looking at carrying out some
interim
internal alterations to um one of our
properties on on on cooper street
um ayte cooper street is currently um a
a office um space that is
vacant and um we've not been able to let
that
and so um there is uh remaining a demand
for some short-term um temporary
accommodation
for the housing team and so we would
like to obtain
agreement to submit a planning
application for a change of use
from the office use
to residential on a temporary basis
the third example
over the page um is is for the provision
of biddeford town council to relocate
their container from victoria park
into the cattle market um
in the interim between when this report
was drafted and published
and the time of this meeting actually
the
town council would prefer to relocate
their temporary
storage facility into the
sports brand in biddeford and an
alternative
location has been identified so actually
as
as a change to this report we would like
to add in
under item three the option to
submit an application for the
cattle market site and also the sports
ground site which is the alternative
location for their container
[Music]
similarly we
would like to apply please for
planning permission to site a storage
container within the
car park members car park of riverbank
house car park if you can
imagine on the left-hand side as you go
into
riverbank car park there is an area
where we currently
store road signs uh cones and other
items there that are related to the
various services um
in that same corner uh what we would
like to do is uh repurpose one of the
containers that will be
um taken uh from the boroughs project
and site it against the boundary wall
there
to use it for storage of
car parking and care taking equipment
and that that will also uh require
consent
obviously a formal application for that
one and
and one uh final item that's uh not on
the list but has
also um come come to uh
for in recent days is the requirement
for
um the enhancements to the skate park
where we need to formally apply
for um any uh acoustic screening that
we're intending for that site
and any landscaping proposals to enhance
it and
and also we've been approached by a
broadband
company that would like to site a uh
storage um
[Music]
kiosk uh in in the corner of the
skatepark site for some
superfast broadband um equipment
so that that's an additional item that's
not in the report but if if members are
minded we would like to obtain approval
for that as well please
so the recommendation there on page two
is the
is the four sites that are listed plus
the variation that i've outlined for
the sports ground and also the addition
of the skatepark
thank you thank you adrian
i note that at least one of these
applications is
what they would call retrospective
now if the council failed to make that
application
the only way the planning officers could
take action is
if they were minded to refuse i can't
see them refusing the
coastal defense works for the best will
in the world
so that is just putting the matter right
for the sake of it isn't it
that that's correct chair thank you
right i've got councillor bushby wishing
to speak
uh thank you chair um i'm quite happy to
support most of the things that um
adrian has highlighted particularly the
acoustic barrier in the skip and the
skate park that would um
you know it's desperately needed and it
will go a long way to
limiting the complaints that we get from
certain residents nearby so looking
forward to that
um i have a problem with the second item
which is 888a cooper street um
conversion of the officer com office
area to
temporary accommodation i'll have some
concerns about that on i have to say
we do get quite a lot of disturbance
in jubilee square and in the town center
from
a variety of um
i gotta watch how i work just because
we're we're live with this but
um some of the more challenging behavior
that we get from
certain people within the town and i
would i would hate for this temporary
accommodation
to um add to that problem which is
already there
it's bad enough as it is and i think it
would be a mistake to have
um i know we we can't always say what
type of
client we're going to get in and
temporary accommodation but
by the very nature of that temporary
accommodation you sometimes do
get people with some challenging
behavior and it is very close to
jubilee square on the town center thank
you
i'm going to call john williams in on
that one right away
thank you chair um i'd have to say i i
would share
cancer bushby's concerns completely um
this really is to increase our options
with regard to
um smaller units of temporary
accommodation and but we would have to
be and we would be
uh very careful about the placement in
that accommodation exactly
for those reasons that you cite
councillor bushby so
um agreement from us and we're well
aware
of those issues and of those concerns
and we'll do our best to uh
to manage that should this be approved
okay counselor mcguff
famous chairman uh go to mr redwood
please debate the acoustics in the
skatepark
was this supposed to be an original
planning wasn't it when we first applied
for this
but it wasn't carried out by tdc
obviously i'm in favor of supporting
this because
we're in desperate need of it can i have
that question answered please
certainly chair happy to answer that
question um this uh
piece of work that we've been looking
into is is not anything that was part of
the original planning application
this is some secondary screening that
will be
required to reduce the effect of the
noise
following the studies that have been
carried out so it's
not anything that was part of any
previous consent
which which is why we need to submit a
new application obviously
councillor christie thank you i've got
no problem with these
uh but the skateboard park has come up
and i too welcome
the idea of an acoustic fence but uh
i've also been approached by a few
people now
uh pointing out the graffiti boards at
the back
which are very heavily used actually and
are really quite entertaining what goes
on there
um they are beginning to fall apart
because they seem to be made of plywood
rather than concrete as we had at the
old skateboard park um i hate to see the
graffiti artist come into town
so could we look at that replacing that
wall fairly soon when we open the
skateboard part
hey jim yes chair we can certainly look
at that
as part of the overall enhancements um i
don't know whether we'll be able to get
it
done in time for when we've reopened the
skatepark because that's actually only a
few weeks away now so um
that that is probably not achievable in
the short term but we will look to it
to to add it as part of the overall
enhancements
thank you councillor um
bushby is a committee member
yes sir however i've had my say
oh right councillor leather
thank you chair you're just a question
on
three on the list and i see there are
five applications all of those of course
will end up coming to the plans
committee at turrage but on the third
one did i hear adrian say that
victoria park will be one of the options
but the sports ground is coming to be
added to it now so there'll be
reports on both of those sites i take it
because just bearing in mind the sports
channel
ground of course is king george v
is a sports ground
that's that's correct chair um the sorry
i should have made it clear the current
biddeford town council container is
already located within victoria park
and the original intention was to
reposition it in
the cattle market bays
the preferred location is now the sports
ground
near to one of the toilet blocks and and
um floodlights
um floodlight towers on on the sort of
um north western corner of the pitch
it's only for a short period of time and
it won't
occupy any um significant uh
playing area that will affect the king
george v
plans at the moment so we're not
intending to
um you know involve them in this process
at the moment
because i just sorry chad i mentioned
victoria park and
what i meant to say was the planning
application will it still be looking at
the
cattle market site as well or not
chair i think it would be advisable for
us to um
perhaps uh apply for both locations
um to to give us the option but
obviously it's
it's fairly straightforward for for each
um each of those so it's not
not really um not really a problem to
put it in for both
thank you chair
right i've got no one else wishing to
speak
can i have a formal proposal please
i'll propose from the chair a second
uh chair thank you coach
right we'll put it to the vote then
thank you chair councillor brenton or
penceler bright
pencil with the exception of item two
four but i'm against item two
ah you can't do that i'm against them
can i just have confirmation counselor
bushby that you are voting against
i am against yes thank you
councillor christie councillor dart
or councillor hicks
or councillor hutchins
councillor james paul penciller laws
oh
against councillor wiseman
or
chair that's four and two against
counselor push me i have you wanting to
speak
no my hand's still up is it yeah
right okay item 13 apple door slip way
um i don't know who's gonna take this
one
okay i think uh stacy's just gonna start
just outlining the
the process under the constitution field
if that's okay yep okay thank you chair
so
um just to remind members this was
originally before
community and resources on the 1st of
february
um following a notice of motion
submitted by councillor ford
um and on the first of february uh the
community resources committee resolved
at the closure of our door slip way for
jet skis
with suitable bullets being positioned
to enable continued access for swimmers
and canoeists
and the decisions and be left to the
harbour board
uh you'd be left to the harbour board um
that mata
that decision was then called in by
councillor pennington
councillor newton councillor jones
councillor mcgough and councillor
langford
so it went to the overview and scruti
scrutiny committee on the 16th of march
um overview and scrutiny recommended
that due to
the wider implications internal
ons do not agree the decision made by
the cnr
committee to bank ban the launching of
jet skis or the closure of ecuador
slipway with the use of bullards
um so that matters now been referred
back to you
today um and the situation today
is community and resources can agree
to follow the recommendation of the ons
committee
um if that happens then that decision
will be deemed implemented today
um if cnr resolves that they don't agree
with the recommendation from overview
and scrutiny
um and want to stick with their original
um
decision on the first of february then
that matter will
be referred back to full council to make
the ultimate decision
as to whether to stand by see an art
decision on the 1st of february
or go along with ons recommendation
on the 16th of march
can i just hand over to the leader chair
just who would like to say a few words
as well
okay thank you chair thank you stacy um
i think we recognize no coaching board
comes before brought this to the council
it's challenging all the issues around
it
we've obviously had everything on social
media but
we're here tonight to decide on whether
we accept
the recommendations from internal or
whether we reject
that recommendation and we go to full
council
what i will do as leader i think in the
short term
i will be asking officers to improve the
signage
and all that side of stuff on the
slipway
but i remove i move that we accept the
recommendations from internal
ons scrutiny of the meeting of the 16th
of march
oh second now councillor bushman
thank you right i have
counsellor locke wishing to speak
yeah i decided to say i was the one that
proposed at the
original cnr and i did so
on the information that was in front of
me one reason that it was called in i
think was to do with a lifeboat
and the slip way being used as an
emergency landing
um launch site so i did a bit of
homework on the lifeboats
um and in 2020 aberdorn life
i had 40 call outs plus 10 stand downs
and up to date in 2021 they had seven
call outs plus two stand downs
and i'd rather note that the boarding
boat is used to access the main boat the
tamar which we all know where that's
board
i couldn't find any history or incidents
of when the slipway was used as an
emergency launchpad
really why the um airport lifeboat
hasn't made any official response
so i just like to say that about the
lifeboat
right the council of brite
thank you chair i mean um i mean i yeah
i didn't i
missed the last meeting i was at work
but i didn't think that a permanent
borrower would be quite the right
solution
but whether we support or
object to this proposal still we still
do have an issue
at the slip wave i mean is there any way
forward on that or we're just
accepting that we go back the way it was
uh chairs
for me as i've been blocked in recent
meetings which i have to have a bit of a
say it is my parish
number 450
you have not been blocked i have three
members wishing to speak your hand has
not yet gone up
i'm just asking before you vote and i
will be listening to you later
as far as councillor bright's question
was concerned
um then i think we've really got to rely
on the officers to
look at alternatives if we're going to
uh go with overview and scrutiny
we've got to see if there are any
alternatives and the officers need to do
that
but in the meantime i'm going to
call on council of lords to speak
nick you're muted sorry about that
thank you chair um first of all
uh i wish to apologize because i made a
poor decision last time
as councillors were not god given to
make the right decisions all the time
and it was a heated debate
and the bollard was almost on the back
burner
and was yeah i just made a bad decision
i want to move on now and i want to say
this
our decision has caused a huge amount of
controversy
and it is divided people um
it it is divided people um
in the parish you're getting you know
people who have sailboats against people
who who want to use jet skis
and uh they'd all muddled through before
and i honestly feel that option a
to accept the recommendation of
internal overview and scrutiny i respect
their decision
and i actually think they were right
this time
we might well in the future want to look
in detail
but at this time coming into the summer
season
i feel that we should go back as much as
we can to the status quo
but definitely improve the signage
speak with the uh bus bus company etc
but we were given information about uh
the seagate the
guests objecting to the noise they made
as far as i know i have not seen and
found
anybody who has received an objection
from them so um yeah i i think we should
go back
and and let the whole thing just calm
down a little
and and uh as for the jet skis
uh we have to look at their behavior
um i don't think it is probably quite as
painted
they appreciate they've got to go to
their area
and return and adhere to
you know the conditions and speed limits
we
request but i think let's just
take a step back and let things calm
down before we look in detail
thank you chair councillor james's award
member
and yeah as a board member
oh thank you chair yeah um yes i
i agree with the support decisions as
far as the bollards go
but the positive impact of that has been
that it's acted as a catalyst really
to bring out the concerns of the various
parties and
there's been a big debate about it
so out of out of a poor decision perhaps
that was a good that was a good thing
um i'm still not happy personally about
jet skis
um being allowed to launch off the
slipway i don't think
um i think there's too much pressure on
church fields
and i um and i think that the estuary is
the wrong place
for jet skis it's an ssi it's a very
delicate
habitat um i would and i
suspect that there's going to be more
pressure from jet skis
as more people come down to the area and
want to
indulge in recreational activities
i don't agree with council laws that we
should just sit back
now and uh consider um
and let's see how it you know go back to
the status quo we've got to urgently
look at the alternative way of
um looking at church fields and i um
i i think uh quite a large number of
local people
think that there should be some sort of
warden system
and i think um officers i think officers
have to have
the direction to do a report on the
implications of that
do the costings um and see
whether that is feasible and to look at
ways of um
funding it um one way has been by
imposing a launching charge
on the on the bigger boats not on canoes
and things
um one could also look at um
cctv or having a system where
wardens go down in the morning and the
after on the evening
or whenever the tides are right but
we've got to look very urgently
at a different way of dealing with
things we also have to look at the way
that church fields is set out the
configuration because uh
there is a problem with bus the bus
being able to turn there
um as someone has said you need really
good signage
um and you need to maybe mark on
on the surface so more clearly where
people are allowed and
where they they aren't but we're
we we've got may or easter coming up and
we're going to have
people huge number of people possibly
coming down to appledore
so they're you know there's a more
urgent situation
of having putting in some sort of
temporary measure before we actually
consider
the longer term measures so um
i think you know we i'm hoping that full
council will
will go that way i mean i'm i agree with
councillor bright
really that um we've got to look at an
alternative
way of dealing with the situation thank
you chair
sean kearney next please
i just wanted to come back um on a point
made by
both both um councillor lock and
councillor haynes there um we we have
received quite a detailed
response from a gentleman called mr
merrell on behalf of the rnli
and that with a whole raft of other
representations that we've received will
give us some really good information on
how
to manage the issues at church field i
think you know coming back on what
council laws just
and sorry councillor haims just said um
we do now know a lot more about apple
door churchfield slipway than we knew a
few weeks back
so like you say if there's one good
thing that's come out of the debate
is that but yes we have received quite a
lot of information now from the rmr
councillor ford now is your opportunity
yeah thanks chair
let's try to get keep positive yeah but
obviously i've had a lot of abuse which
i have which all right for 98 pain a
week i've got to take it on the chin
let's deal with facts and i should say
i've told you many times i've probably
bordered the deaf in there
i have got a level a law and i do deal
in fact so let's keep it to the thing go
forward i did have a positive meeting
this morning and
coach reigns will substantiate that with
several different users at nine o'clock
christian gov was invited from a jet ski
club now what's important going forward
bearing in mind historically the
mistakes that this council has made and
cost us lots of money
i want it i've asked many times for that
club to substantiate
they're a club when i've asked the canoe
gig club right away constitution comes
up
all the rules got it within the next day
i've repeatedly asked for that
number one before i go any further chair
could you ask legal or anybody
if they've actually carried out my
request and asked
if the pwc got a constitution could you
do that please before i continue
we'll ask the question
i've not asked that question chair um
why not
because it sorry councillor ford i
hadn't realized you'd ask that but it
wasn't
relevant for this notice of motion for
me to go back to that that club to a
certain
um if they've got a constitution from
our perspective any member of the public
is entitled to make a contribution
towards any of our committees
um right let's just labor a little bit
longer than i want because it's gonna be
a long beaten i
actually would like to go back to my
allotment right
uh we've got the leader of the council
here mr james right
was it not true with yourself
uh sean carney and the chief exec
that some months ago i actually asked
important today
this fact that they have not come
forward with the constitution
i'm happy to take a lie detector test
please give a response
joe i'm not sure of the relevance of
that to this notice of motion
to the decision from cnr or to the
decision of ons
at the end of the day cnr made a
decision based on the notice of motion
submitted by council of ford
i am not sure if it's relevant whether
they have a constitution
the public are entitled to contribute
towards any of our committee meetings
and i don't need to question their
credentials when doing so
so what you're saying is if somebody
says they're a club when you've done a
scrutiny it doesn't matter whether a
club or not that's what you're saying
yes or no
what i'm saying chair is anybody is
entitled to contribute towards any of
our
our district council meetings that they
are public meetings and
it's not a matter for the council
to question a club or an individual's
credentials
when submitting a public contribution
towards our committees
or towards the council as a whole
so it's irrelevant whether somebody's a
club or not then when you're actually
taking on board their evidence
and they're making sweeping statements
so it doesn't matter whether they're a
club or not only fight or not
then then i've labeled then just give me
one more response and then we'll carry
on thank you
councillor james is looking to speak on
this matter and he was mentioned by
councillor ford
yeah um yeah i'm quite happy to confirm
we have had those discussions
uh and again as our sisters just said
um i'm not sure the relevance of it
however
what i am prepared to say is leader and
probably get myself in trouble
um whether they're a constitutional
group or not
probably having as it's been said
brought this all to everybody's
attention it would be up to them though
to perhaps reform
um a constitutional club if they wish to
do
but in terms of bringing noted um
statements to this council
i take it any one of them can come and
say they are member
members of the club um a lot of us are
members of clubs they're not institut
i've got constitutions
um but i think the problem here is is
that we're wandering away
from what's before us i think what we
have said is we're
we're looking at bringing more uh
signage
we are upping our um because we expect
to have
traffic problems and that which is not
actually directly
related to this um recommendations but
we are looking at
um increasing our attendance um car
parking attendance we are looking at
trying to coordinate them with the um
the tides so that will although we won't
be able to do all of them because
obviously
there are all times of the day but we're
looking to do what we can in the day
so that will ease that position and i
think going forward there's a lot of
issues here and i've spoke to coaster
ford at length and he knows i have
and i have a certain amount of sympathy
with him in terms of the jet skis
and i think probably we do
need to have more discussions about that
but the issue tonight is
is do we accept either the
recommendation of internal scrutiny
or we reject it and i'm quite happy to
have other discussions
with various members and various groups
to look at the way forward
once we've sorted out what we're here to
do tonight
right now for i'll just come back to
that recommendation
right and sure i'll just wind up another
minute let's go forward yeah good idea
um what i would like to make obvious a
lot of people
it's um mr baltier forget the pun
correct me if i'm wrong was this not
brought up first on august the 10th
could that be confirmed by the council
please
yeah if it helps i can confirm that the
notice of motion was submitted by
councillor ford on august the 10th
good so at least we're agreeing on
something that's a step forward
so why is it took until february the
first
to send it to cnr now i mean funny
general public i always listen to this
please give me a simple not pitfall a
simple answer why it took so long thank
you
[Music]
point of order chair come on can i ask
what this has to do with the motion that
we are supposed to be debating
i i will explain that actually mr
cleverklogs is that right
yes you go on councillor ford thank you
very much us again i was julie elected
as mr hutchins was mr honorable hutchins
why is irrelevant is mr mclaughlin voted
for the borrowers
right fact actually said any evidence
said there wasn't any evidence now let's
be honest so why is it took
six months not to provide evidence
everybody
all you people it's always all of a
sudden realize there's a problem there
that i brought to the attention because
that's what my public want me to do
that is enough for the day but my god i
have only just started thank you chair
right we'll move on councillor christie
thank you mr chairman um i'm going back
to something councillor haim said that
um i agree with him we can't just let
the situation continue
uh i've had lots of phone calls and
emails i'm sure the rest of you have
um and it strikes me this is uh the dog
poo
problem all over again uh
everyone who's contacted me the jet
skiers they're all the
jet skiers who follow the rules and are
very careful
it's like the dog poo situation whenever
you raise it and you're gonna you talk
about
cracking down on people who let their
daughter you get lots of phone calls
from the considerate dog owners you
never hear from the ones who couldn't
give a toss
it's the same way with this because when
i was talking to the jet skiers about
this
the clear implication is that the locals
follow the rules it's those people who
come from up country
suddenly turn up they launch off the
slipway they're the ones
you know the problem and we really do
need uh to address this and
i will follow councillor james what he's
just said when this
does come to full council as i suspect
it is going to
we need to have a range of options
because at the moment the only options
being put forward are the bollards
we need to have a range of options so as
councillors we can actually
decide what to do and those options are
going to have to address the traffic
problems on the car park which seem to
have been
lost a bit in terms of jet skis um
but they affect more people all year
than
the jet skis just turn up certain times
of year um
so can i ask when this does go to full
council we do get a full range of
options
available to the councillors thank you
well it depends on the vote tonight
whether it goes to the full council and
not come to the christie
because if we vote to accept the
overview and scrutiny it doesn't go to
full council
councillor lock yeah if we do
go and approve ons can we add an
addendum or can we not do that because
i'm also concerned that we cannot afford
to put it on the back burner
we need to you know get all our
ducks in orders exactly what we're going
to do so i'm quite prepared to agree to
oweness with an addendum
that an action plan must be in place
because i've listened i've opened all
the emails that we've had sent
and there was an interesting one from a
resident of [ __ ] martin
and he states that jet skis are becoming
a nuisance in the danger there at coop
mountain
and these are just banning jet skis from
the whole of the estuary
over which we have jurisdiction i mean i
don't know whether that's possible and
that could be something that could be
added to our
plans of the future
i think there lies the problem we don't
have sufficient jurisdiction
chancellor hutchings
um yeah just i've never had so many
representations over one
bollard and quite amazing that the the
vast um
variety of places that people come from
so i agree with councillor haines i'm
councillor christie that there's a huge
amount more to discuss here rather than
just the bollards
and i was also going to suggest as
council lock did if we did vote on this
today to agree with ons
is whether that we could agree on um a
fuller report from officers
um as sean kearney has said they've got
a lot more information about the rnli
now
so whether we get a much better report
on on on our way ahead
could i have steve hurst next please
uh thank you i've initially put my hand
up to respond to
councillor ford's question around the
the timing of the report and
he'd indicated been a delay um members
will be aware that
during the course of the last year we've
had a number of
notices of motion put forward many of
them
um had time implications uh
associated with them we're also dealing
with
or have been still dealing with a
pandemic this particular notice of
motion
requested that actually be taken by this
easter
is coming easter which is why it
didn't have the same level of priority
as the
the other notes motions which required
works to be done
during last year it was discussed with
councillor ford
the timing of this and obviously was
brought forward in time
that should anything be implemented it
could have been implemented by this
easter so that's the reason for the
for the the timing of this notes motion
coming forward
to committee um obviously um
members of and uh council hutchins just
referred to
other types of reports what we've got to
remember
is that the notice of motion was brought
forward to ban jet skis so it's banning
jet skis
that the committee are considering
whether a to ban them or b
not to ban them that was what the notice
of motion was about
that's what the report that was
originally come to committee
was about and that's what you're trying
to
resolve tonight whether to stick with
your original decision to ban jet skis
and the the purpose of the way of
managing that was by imposition of
bollards
which obviously internal ovum scrutiny
has suggested
no you shouldn't be balancing jet skis
and no you shouldn't be having
uh bollards in place so that's that was
the purpose of the notes motion that was
the purpose of the report
not to consider any alternate
options about what to do with the river
or what to do with the
estuary that would be subject to
something completely different
as council james uh set out earlier it's
about
this single pet thing that's being dealt
with this evening
thank you steve councillor james
counselor james you're muted i've lost
the picture as well
i'm back on though um partly could i
just say that
i did raise this earlier today with our
officers and i don't want to fall over
them
but i i was uh slightly frustrated with
the fact that
we are not looking at a way forward
tonight we need to decide on what we're
going to do and the only
acceptable one at the moment to my mind
is that we accept our nasa's
recommendation
but we do need to look at this there's
so much
um discussion uh put that that way
mildly um that is coming up
and as leader i will be asking our
officers of a way forward that we can
look at alternatives and then we present
that
and what we do and i should probably get
in trouble for doing it but i feel that
we've got to that stage
where we actually need to be a bit more
proactive on this issue
thank you thank you james listening to
the debate
so far i come to the conclusion that the
membership of this committee
is quite strong that they would want you
to do that and put
pressure on the officers to bring
forward an all-embracing report
counselor bush be next
thank you chair um just for information
purposes can i
have some idea of the number of
complaints regarding jet skis that were
lodged with uh taurus as a council say
over the last year or two
is there a number do we know you know is
it a large number is it none is it
you know i have no idea
yeah i can respond um i don't have the
exact number but
it was a few uh
not lots but there is certainly concern
if you proactively talk to people about
the issue so if you were to go down to
ecuador
and talk to people um do they think that
sometimes there's
misbehavior by jessica uses yes
how many people then actually bother to
complain very few
thank you uh jan williams popped up
wanting to speak to us now
uh sorry chair um sean has answered the
question thank you
right okay counselor laws
council laws you're muted yes chair i
will be brief
um i i i'm still concerned that we've
got a divided community here and we're
not
easing that approaching the season yes
we need report we need to sort out the
future
but knee-jerk within a few weeks when
everybody is so divided i don't think
is the way now something does concern me
which is is related and that is we're in
a pandemic
we have covered guidelines
and i don't think they include holding a
meeting
uh in the fresh air on on
on on the parking ground um
i i think that was ill-advised uh
it does not comply thank you chair
thank god right
i've got no one else wishing to speak
yeah i've been trying to speak i can't
seem to get um
a response i'm sorry i have now got
councillor
brenton and councillor lot wishing to
speak i believe
councillor brim uh thank you chair um
firstly i don't know exactly what we're
gonna vote on in a minute because it's
not clear on the
on the screen at all but nevertheless
we'll deal with that in a minute
i mean this obviously this issue has
been going on for some time as
councillor ford will
doubtless know that his father when he
was on the council some
25 years ago raised this issue because
it was a problem then
the problem really lies and i think if
stacy would
care to do a bit of homework on it is is
maritime law
which of course is an absolute nightmare
in its own right
and thanks to henry viii we englishmen
can uh
launch a vessel from any point of our
coast
at any time for any purpose that's why
all the nutters come over to
britain in their bathtubs with or
without sink plugs in them
to go off to america and various other
things they can be prevented in france
and spain that but it can't be here
because we're supposed to get our skills
at seamanship
so therefore we get anybody can launch
from our coast
and that that is a crux of it really i
can i think the other
possibility i don't know whether it's
been discussed very much is
actually the um banning of trailers
being parked in the car park down there
i don't know how that would work but
clearly
you know it's a it's an absolutely
insurmountable
problem and at the end it will boil down
to sensible behavior and good
citizenship on the part of those people
who use the water by enlarge the yachts
people and all the people who use the in
the estuary
have a good code of conduct or conduct
or rather
where they they do look after one
another they watch out for one another
in many years i've been on there sailing
and what have you
it's been good but you it's always as
counselor christie pointed out it's
always the odd one or two
that spoil it and really they're the
ones that need to be ostracized and we
need to take some measures to deal with
them
thank you for the lock yeah can i do
some clarification from stacy then
we cannot add um an addendum to the
recommendation from ons
something like officers to draw up
explicit plans
for the continued safe use of the
slipway could we do that or not
yeah no council look we can't so the the
only options available today
are to um confirm cnr's original
decision
or um confirm uh that you agree with the
recommendation by owen esque um qbc and
i can't
make an addendum to another committee
decision
councilor haims oh no
sorry who said oh no thank you chair
um yeah i was going to ask for that
clarification
so it seems to me is that right may i
ask stacey
through you chair that the only way is
for
a counselor to put down the motion at
full council
which would um ask for what we're
wanting
for what you are wanting on this
committee are full full reports and
investigation of options
that it's down to a councillors put
forward a motion is that right please
yes councillors that's absolutely
correct we need to remember this is
following on from the
the notice of motion um uh proposed by
councillor ford in the first instance
that noticed emotion was agreed by full
council to go forward
um so we can't amend that notice of
motion so
anything further would have to be a new
notice of motion
um by um
an another councillor or council afford
himself at a further full council
meeting
um and what you're looking to be
reviewed
i think the the important point to raise
here
is that we only as a council have
control of the slipway we don't have
control of the estuary
and so that's really important to bear
in mind which is is why the original
notification i believe came forward
in relation to um banning uh jet skis
from the actual slipway because that's
what we do
control as a council
councillor christie yeah thank you um
that does seem the the right way to go
can i ask
would councillor james put forward a
motion to the next fall council
asking that um for a series of options
if our count if our
officers can prepare that could we
suspend the standing orders at full
council and discuss this motion then
because there is a time element here
and uh i don't know if councillor
brenton would agree to that but
um i think this is a situation where we
need to do
that because clearly there
is a problem here maybe small in terms
of the numbers but it's quite important
in terms of health and safety
and we need to expedite it so
i wonder if councillor james will put
that forward i'd certainly second
uh his motion asking for a range of
options as to what we do
and can i just point out we do actually
control some of the estuary
uh the estuary within the harbour board
is controlled by the harbour board
and we have quite a lot of power
uh steve harris funding to speak
thanks chair i'm sure stacey will
clarify the the
uh setting aside of standing orders to
discussion notes emotion which i believe
uh can't be done so i believe that no
disposal would just be voted on
and forwarded to a committee should it
get supported
i think it's it's worthwhile here just
um i know councillor james alluded to it
uh when he spoke earlier just to kind of
emphasize a bit more
obviously we we are aware of um
some of the issues within appledore as
well as some
other coastal areas um around westwood
ho and so forth
um and this year probably more probably
than last year there's going to be a
higher number of tourists coming into
the area
wanting to use our facilities
so we have been discussing over the
morning
and last week about additional resources
we need to put
into these areas to help support those
communities
and to help facilitate things moving
and operating properly in the car park
areas
in the coastal community communities so
that's something we are already putting
in place
obviously last year members will recall
that there were things around street
marshals in place
uh providing extra visibility extra
support
to communities and john williams again
we'll be looking at that for this coming
year so we are putting additional
resources
into helping support communities helping
things move uh more efficiently through
car parks through
uh public ways we'll be doing that in
collaboration with the county council
because obviously
things that uh people parking
on the highways causes problems and the
leader and
i have a meeting with other devon
leaders
and other chief executives tomorrow
morning looking at how we work together
um over the coming weeks uh working
through the government's road map around
opening up and the impacts that will
have so there are things we're looking
at
and that's just i guess to give members
uh some assurance that
some of these things will be addressed
during the coming months and obviously
through that process we'll be able to
gather
and see some of the things that are
happening on the ground
and would be would better position us
uh in to enable kind of options and
things to be sought
thanks chair councillor james
yes chair thank you um i've got
scribbled notes all over the place most
of it i can't read after i've scribbled
it
but we are putting in more resources um
if i could come back to coaster christie
a minute
i would be happy to put something to
full council once we've looked at what
we're putting out the problem with
notice emotions are
is that we're tied a bit to what the
notice of motion is
so i think that the way forward is for
me to ask and work with officers
to look at all the problems around this
area and
come back to um to all of you whether in
email
or full council it's short next week
unfortunately where we we tell you we
discuss with you
what we can do something about and what
we're doing about what we can do
something about
and and what at the moment we cannot do
anything about it's
the old saying of the unknowns of the uh
the unknown unknowns are the most
frightening thing
so i think yeah we've got to move
forward we need to adopt what's on the
agenda tonight because that's what we're
dealing with
um but i'm determined that i will be
talking to
um officers i'm talking to members and
perhaps people outside the members
that are affected by all what's going on
around
apple door with the parking of the
traders parking in the cars
the camper vans and and given an update
to everybody on what we can do
and what we are doing um and
highlighting what is just slightly
behind our control
um and what we may have to look at in
that respect
so i'm happy to go forward with that
i'm sorry uh so i i think the most
sensible thing is
that as leader i ensure that we do
tackle all these things
and come back to members with everything
um
and if it goes to full council it needs
to go
as a slightly targeted notice of motion
or we go into this
ridiculous situation where if it's not
what's worded
it has to go round in a circle we just
need to
we just need to deal with it and
at home and most of you in businesses
when you have a problem you deal with it
and i think we're in that situation
let's get some clarity
to the situation and move forward
okay chair but we do need to vote on the
two
that's on the sheet tonight i would like
to think that that report comes back to
full council in about seven weeks time
councillor pennington is chair of
internal by the way chair thank you just
a simple question is perry going to
affect all this because it's a bit
politicized i fancy having talked to
friends down out the door at the present
moment
um are we going not to be able to touch
it until after the devon county council
elections
i'll ask for guidance on that one from
stacy please
thank you uh council pension and we can
still proceed
with any council business um the purdue
rules come to
um publicizing it or publicizing any
statements from
um councillors um but for obvious
reasons we do try and avoid um any very
contentious matters during the
peripheral period
and so it doesn't actually stop us from
doing anything it does stop us from
publicizing or making statements on
behalf of individual counselors
are you chair councillor leather
thanks chair well i can't see why the
leader of the council
councillor james and the chairman of the
council councillor brenton
can't ask our officers to come up with a
report a full report
on the issue of the slipway and jet skis
and possible
solutions to the issues down there to
come it
not have a nose bring it as an agenda
item to full council
and let's discuss it at full council in
june probably
when we've got when the officers have
had time to make a full report on the
issues
and then it could be it's not a notice
of motion it's an agenda item on full
council
and we can discuss it then sure
thank you right i've got
a proposal and it's been proposed and
seconded uh councillor james proposed it
i think it was counselor lock that
seconded it
i'm going to put it to the vote
councillor brush with a second dinner
sorry can we just hear it again can you
read it out
i i proposed counselor um
christie that we accept the
recommendations from internal overview
and scrutiny committee
uh the meeting of march the 16th and and
to make it absolutely clear
is that that we do not accept the
recommendation from cnr that we go back
to what would be status quo
well we have further discussions that's
only my bit added what you're voted on
is for a except the recommendations from
internal scrutiny
yeah okay okay
yeah that's exactly it
right go to the vote thank you chair
councillor brenton
councillor brenton
because the brenton you're muted
i'll come back to cancer brenton
councillor bright before councillor
bushby
or answer christy oh
penciller dart for
pencil hex for pencil hutchins
oh
or council wiseman or
councillor brenton finally i unmute my i
got unmuted yes four thank you
that's unanimous chair thank you
right i believe now we move into
part two if we possibly can
so i i would um
ask them i would propose that we move
into part two from the chair
is there a seconder i'm happy to second
can uh chair counselor james james
can we take a formal vote please
thank you chair councillor brenton
four councillor bright
or ancillary or
councillor christie cancel the dart
for pencil hicks or
pencil hutchins
for pencil james for
penciling laws or penciller lock
or pencil mcgough or
pencil wiseman or unanimous chair
thank you so at this point i thank
members of the public who've been
watching in
we appreciate the fact that you take an
interest in the work of the council
we hope we behave as